like I told a story of a girl from
college who cheated on her boyfriend
okay now look guys what I learned with
cheating is I have been the tattletale
before I have been the tattletale we're
both the men and the women what I've
learned is it doesn't matter people are
gonna stay or they're gonna go half the
time they already know and every time I
have tattletals it has done nothing but
caused me problems you know for people
that I'm not even that good of friends
with so if I see cheating and it's I'm
not that close with the girl on my team
and this in this situation or the guy or
whatever it is call me crazy I just try
to stay out of that that is not my not
my business